في جميع انحاء بريطانيا شلل شبه تام
واضطراب حقيقيه لوح في الافق لمده شهر
كامل والسبب هو امتناع عمال السكك
الحديديه عن العمل وفق تقرير صادر عن
صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه فان عمال السكك
الحديديه تركوا وظائفهم وخاضوا اضرابا
عاما متسببين في تعطيل 80% من حركه
القطارات والغاء العديد من الرحلات والسم
مخاوف كبيره من طرف حكومه صنعاء التي وجدت
نفسها عاجزه امام هاجز الاضرابات المتكرره
التي تشهدها البلاد منذ العام الماضي
والتي يمكن ان تستمر هذه المره في شهر
كامل بسبب تراجع طبعا المستوى المعيشي
وتدهور القدره الشرائيه والتي دفعت
بالعشرات من الموظفين في بريطانيا
للمطالبه برفع الاجور خصوصا وان بريطانيا
تشهد ارقاما قياسيه في معدلات التضخم حيث
بلغت اعلى مستوياتها خلال واحد 41 عاما
بوصول معدلات التضخم الى ما يق 11%
لا يتقاضون رواتبهم مقابل اضرابتهم ايضا
لذا فهذا يعني الكثير
جدا موازنه ذلك ولست متاكدا تماما من
الاستنتاج الذي يمكن استخلاصه انهم
يقاتلون من اجل رفاهيتهم وسبل عيشهم
من الواضح
حقا عندما تضطر الى اضافه وقت اضافي الى
تنقلاتك لكنني في النهايه اؤيد حقهم في
الاضراب تماما وان لديهم الاسباب للقيام
بذلك
وسائل الاعلام بريطانيه اكدت بان حمى
الاضطرابات في طريقها الاجتياح قطاعات
اخرى وليس فقط قطاع النقل والجو حيث من
المقرر ان يبدا الممرضون وقوات حرس الحدود
وسائقه سيارات الاسعاف الى جانب موظفي
قطاعات اخرى اضرابا هذا الشهر اضرابات
وضعت الحكومه في موقف محرج ما دفعها طبعا
الى التفكير في مناقشه تعبئه الجيش لتوفير
الخدمات العامه الحيويه بالتزامن مع فصل
الشتاء وتحسبا لازمه الطاقه التي تشهدها
البلاد وتاتي حمله الاضطرابات هذه في
توقيت الحساس من السنه حيث تتزامن مع فتره
اعياد الميلاد ما قد يؤثر على موسم
الاحتفالات السنويه في بريطانيا